are you shorting the market are you
betting stocks will drop because retail
investors and day Traders are doing it
more and here's how inverse exchange
rated funds like the pro shares short S
P 500 ETF s p goes down you win although
it may not be one four minus one there
are various risks and costs that quickly
pile up if using for more than one
single day so keep that in mind
[Music]
another way to bet against the market is
by shorting individual stocks you can do
that on etoro or Robin Hood for example
and apparently new short positions have
run up a lot almost two-thirds higher
than this time last year or so you're
more experienced going short using a put
option or on margin but this is where
the risks rack up when the market
rallies you lose and if using borrowed
money you can lose more than you put in
even the Market's biggest pessimists
they are expecting some moves higher as
we get closer to year end and remember
this time of year is usually pretty good
for stocks the S P 500 gained on average
four percent in the final quarter during
the past 20 years
when you're short and the market goes
the other way that is up
your losses could be unlimited so trade
carefully
thank you